Billy's bucket list began the episode
Billy is still dead I was kind of hoping
he'd be back I just say like no no he
wasn't dead they just cloned his skin or
something but no he's really dead I yeah
wearing his real skin is much better and
when I come across at the beginning of a
rap battle the best rap battle ever may
I say good god how do I know I can keep
up with us to drop the mic um he comes
across a Kenyan who was Billy's
ex-girlfriend and she just feels bad
that Billy's still gone and Jake's
clearly in denial and so they decided
let's go to go to his crack let's go to
his crack and they go in there and they
find this the crack is infested by
fairies yes infested by fairies I like
to point out I remembered a character
that you did or at least a voice said to
you oh yeah yeah that the mark hamill
not only did that king of the fairies
think he was also the fear that came out
of the fear Feaster came out of Finn's
stomach so I knew that I got that right
I'm terrible with voices well I'm
terrible with names so hello Matthew
Broderick that was beautiful um we'll
frame that moment yes so they um they
decide they they find the bucket list
Billy's bucket list and they decide to
do all the things on there which is like
you know one sit still thin that thing
and there was like ride motorcycle one
last time and they right over this cliff
and it blows up and it's awesome and you
know kandi thinks it's cool so she goes
back home and then the last thing is
that he has to line the ocean in water
so of course fins die in the ocean it's
been a long day okay that log down do a
lot before I go to a convention
sometimes my backwards I get my words
okay okay sandable so they go into the
ocean and water and well I mean I guess
technically you could lie in the ocean
like in a boat there you go don't try to
make sense of my rambling can only get
her well people are gonna yell at me
anyway so he goes he confronts his fear
again the fear Feaster comes back but he
confronts him and he has this weird
dream I think it's a dream where he
loses his hat a wheel takes it and then
the Hat grows big the wheel comes out
but he confronts it and sure enough he's
in the water in the ocean and looks in
the Stars there's Billy and Billy just
stalks him thanks so much you know and
now I can be at these as real hero by
the way your father's alive
and that was the season finale for that
and what a dad the human not die happy
human there was a real bad yeah and he
tells him where he is even in the so I
do think that's a pretty solid season
finale I like it because it's not most
of the other ones and for the most part
are like these really big cliffhangers
are really big epic episodes and this
one's mostly sort of you know cut down
played and sort of but returns towards
the old roots like within being afraid
of water and sort of these old
characters and nothing really major
going on and then suddenly just boom
this big huge chunk of information that
just makes I'm sure anybody watching it
go wah and it's a great place to leave
off so uh I liked especially after the
last like five or six that like just
crammed in so much it was nice to have
one that was really laid-back and a
little slower and kind of cool and then
just like this huge you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah I was one of those I would
the other faces were priceless uh I
absolutely loved this at first I was
gonna actually as he presses play I'm
like word on the minutes what about
Billy and he's and he's Ally she said
exactly like that
exactly like you know Angie thumbs like
just Shh just watch and I was like but
I'm gonna call this but yeah these
people really like to you know no I
don't care so um I liked Canyon a lot
there's something about her I really
enjoyed I liked just the relationship I
guess between Canyon and fin they kind
of come together and become friends
through Billy knowing Billy mutually and
and I thought it was really neat I
thought it was a very natural friendship
I really enjoyed it especially with Finn
honestly just the only real friendship
he has is with Jake otherwise really be
most kind of there but he doesn't I
don't think you don't you dare talk bad
about people I love B'Elanna I just
don't feel that finn considers BMO his
friend i think Finn considers BMO as
this little guy that lives in their
house I don't think he sees BMO like he
sees Jake I disagree well good for you
I think sees BMO as a friend but not
someone like hey I can talk to you about
stuff and you can offer beg well Jake's
brother Jake is Finn's brother ah so
there's obviously that stronger
connection well so besides BMO and Jake
I mean
his interactions I mean with bubblegum
and Flame Princess recently it's like ah
and so it's really refreshing to see
just this very sweet very natural like
hey we kind of you know we're getting to
know each other and look we have
something in common how cool is that and
just do this thing you know and and even
when they're saying goodbye you know
he's like so maybe I'll see you around
and she's like yeah sure and and they
just do like a fist bump in it it was
really nice I really liked that a lot
I'm sad that we don't see a lot of Jake
at first I was like yeah Jake's back but
he's still not which I guess is okay the
one while saying it the one interesting
thing that about halfway through I did
sort of go yeah wait a minute is that
you know it's good to have like a good
relationship with like you know there's
someone you date or whatever but the
same thing you do circle yeah why did
they break up they specifically wrote
her as ex-girlfriend yeah you never saw
why they broke up so you could always
assume a me just didn't work out
whatever me they're still friends or
like maybe something really big happened
like ant you feeling guilty and came
back to you now that he's dead I mean
that can bring even the worst of enemies
out video games and stuff that's right
he get lazy and watched movies all day
long and it pans over you know I was too
busy watching the movie about the video
game over there so I get distracted yeah
I do remember that though okay that
brings me flower thing I like the fact
that it is an ex-girlfriend and it's
like oh they still have like a cool
relationship it seems like you know yeah
you know you gotta think like
ex-girlfriend at a funeral like you can
go for a lot of jokes you know I tell
you a lot of that dumb mean he acts
tough you did but it's like no I was
still cool they they treat it really
like two people who never met coming
together and finding out more through a
mutual friend who has passed away
I mean really what it is so yeah
that too that's it I this is one of the
best episodes I've seen oh really like
at that much in a long time I do really
love it I love exactly what you said I
love the pacing of it where it's kind of
like well stuff is happening but we're
pretty laid back I mean it's just a neat
little episode and then right at the end
it's like oh no dad dad the human would
and then you're like um I can't I kind
of really like that I like that it made
me screech I liked the possibility to
that's it it's the possibility of
something new of learning something new
I love Ice King he's one of my favorites
and I love that the Simon's storyline
but I'm dying to see more about fit I'm
dying to see is this true is this really
his dad and what the hell and this whole
human thing because he is a human amidst
everything that is not I just so many
questions it opens up so many questions
so many possibilities and maths and and
all of them positive oh no I think you
guys are right I mean the thing is with
this one is this feels like an adventure
time episode yeah other ones felt like
Adventure Time episodes that we're
trying to get a lot in there this one
just felt natural it felt like we were
kind of going back a season and it just
felt like you could watch it have a good
time I mean other it wasn't heavy it
wasn't like anything like to tug on any
of your heartstrings or any of your
emotions it was just kind of like boom
it's there
oh man okay he's dealing with the loss
of his friend he's gonna help Baba okay
all that stuff he's interacting with a
female where either she's not crushing
on him and he or he's not crushing on
her like anytime there he's interacting
with a female for the most part that
seems to be what it is and I know it's
not always but like that's kind of the
majority of what happens and this is
just one where it's like yeah yeah we
both like bill you were both close to
him let's hang in a sense plus some
great lines bit here's Billy's loincloth
and starches like that stinks I loved
wouldn't finish looking at the list and
he says tell pin that thing and it's
like oh that's gonna bother me for the
rest of my life I mean he ends up
finding it out but I love just hearing
him say that because just imagine like
let's say I died tomorrow and you see
this thing and it says tell Doug that
thing I wanted to tell him since the day
I met him or something like that Doug
you're gonna be like god dammit ya never
know what the hell this is just how he
does it's always gonna bug him but it's
all he's so commonplace about it huh
let's go bug me forever yes I love
that's one of my favorite lines I like
to again it's closing more doors there's
no more fear Feaster fear Feaster is
gone he killed the fear Feaster he
conquered his fear of the ocean it's
it's I think the kids you know the team
or whatever is trying to close a bunch
of doors so they can open up new doors I
like the new doors people seem to you
know it happens in all cartoons where
you know you have this set of characters
and most people don't want that set of
characters to change you don't want any
of them leaving in any way shape or form
and I think with Adventure Time what I
really like is they're not afraid to sit
there and say okay you know what Billy's
dad Billy's gone I mean they took him
out which I give them credit for there
they seem to be saying okay lemonhope
we're kind of done with lemonhope you
know we're not gonna be seeing them
again like and we're dislike them I mean
given I'm surprised you know that
they're willing to go that far a lot of
cartoons it'll be like okay here we are
on the couch this is us oh look here's
our guest a character for one episode
and then you never see that character
ever again Adventure Time has a habit of
bringing back characters that you expect
to only be there for only that one
episode like root beer guy was in this
episode
granted it was kind of in the background
and everything but he's still there
like they're consistently bringing back
minor characters which most cartoons
don't do or most shows don't even do but
at the same time they're not they're not
afraid to sit there and go okay
we had lemonhope we've figured out what
we're gonna do with him done over with I
like that I like that there's beginnings
and closures in the show well that's the
fine thing to me your time out these
past few episodes where they're just
trying to so close off these doors and
acts off these characters and stuff and
it's like they've kind of done that
before but they haven't done so many in
a row I think you think it maybe one
time where I was saying like you know
we're getting quite a few of these intro
can we get kind of a lighter one and
then they opened up again but yeah it's
like these past few have not only been
really heavy but they've just been
cramming so much uh yeah it's kinda
these past five episodes at them like
transformers the anime that movie like
no these characters are dead now now
it's time for these new characters and
new stories favorite movie of all time
I can quote that like I can from
beginning to end including all of the
music everything else is crap
performance but ya know I thought this
was like you said it really felt like
Adventure Time and not to say like what
am i watching this is an adventure time
it's like yes it is I mean but it's so
much is crammed into it it's it's like
we're watching three it's like we're
watching big events in adventure time
which is like it's always fine they've
had big events but silly they have like
five in a row it's like you kind of
missed the actual show for a bit yeah
you know you had five events and then
finally an episode yeah you know so yeah
you know I love event I like I said but
there they are best based out so yeah no
I do it I definitely throw it's pretty
solid I thought was really good yeah
season finale - because that just leaves
people just really wanting more but
still being satisfied with one
like if you told me this was the season
finale going in I'd be watching sup asou
like well it's fine but it's a shame
that's not like I don't know cliffhanger
or whatever and then just boom right in
your face like what and then it's going
dude okay if I were someone watching
this oh okay this is my or whatever but
ya know so I definitely liked it I don't
know why we're still talking when we
could watch the next to the next episode
really yes not you you're you're
watching the field are you gonna be
doing this like dumb Batman thing really
with the whole to the next step so
that's what I'm expecting you to do well
like a logo comes out like yeah really
what you're gonna do well to the next
episode